You've just implemented the choice question
[UNKNOWN],
and used it in a program that displayed two choice questions. Previously, you
had written a program that presents two plain questions. Can we mix the two?
How can we write a program that presents a plain question, and then a choice
question? Should we provide two present question methods? One for questions,
one for choice questions, or is it okay to provide a single present question
method who's parameter has type question, and use that to present both the
question and the choice question? Or should the parameter of that single method
have type choice question? Or, are we trying the impossible? What do you think?